[Music]
these guys are pretty freaking amazing
right oh my god is this what is this
this is these guys are both bear cubs oh
my god so you have a brown bear cub
that's a European brown bear and this is
a North American oh this is the greatest
thing I've ever seen they are adorable
and I have children I love this I have
two children and I love this bear more
than Mike I'll tell you what you you
love it now but when these guys get big
again these are not animals that regular
people can have as pets
even though believe it or not some
people try do you want to hold they're
not regular people we're on TV
yeah sorry that's so if you want to tip
the bottle up like this like this okay
sorry sorry he's gonna remember that
when he's let's grown and in the wild
didn't say let's see if we can get her
take the bottle here anyone want a
little google sauce she's not really
interested so we'll we'll just let her
hang on your arms yeah that's cuz it's
pepto-bismol you're giving up oh oh
getting angry getting angry no you
wanted to take her no no I love this in
well I just want her not to hate me so
these animals obviously live in
captivity only people that you know are
in zoos that have licenses that give
them veterinary care can ever have a
bear as a pet I think this bear heard
from the owl that this shows no good but
it's undeniable that at this stage in
life they're absolutely adorable these
guys are only a few weeks old this is
this bear is gonna get to be a thousand
pounds and the black bear over here it
will only get to be maybe you know four
hundred pounds so incredible a thousand
pounds and this will kill me if I see it
in the 100 percent will come and kill
you if it sees you in the wild yeah 100%
and only me remember me you're gonna see
you're gonna see me on a hiking trail
and you're gonna remember that I spilled
pepto-bismol in your forehead there is
some good news for these guys black
bears are doing really well here in
North America and some of the endangered
populations like that in Louisiana are
actually being taken off the endangered
species list same for some populations
of brown bears here and in North America
as well so that's actually good
oftentimes with wildlife it's not good
news it's
we're wiping them out they're declining
but these are two species that are doing
fairly well because of the work of
conservation organizations like the
National Wildlife Federation so I always
like to share the good news when when we
can a good look at that now in a few
weeks we wouldn't be able to do this
these guys are still tiny and I get that
big that fast yeah well they just you
know they're like human kids you know
they grow quickly and they're developed
quickly and right now they're really not
able to do much than just you know kind
of be cute and nurse I'm giving him a
like a shiatsu massage and he seems to
like it
yeah I'm just be okay with it he's
obviously relaxing a little bit get the
neck get this area here but you can see
when they're this cute somebody you know
with enough money and the will to want
to go out and get one of these as a pet
I'm gonna this is gonna be mine you're
gonna take this and you say it's gonna
get big but I don't believe you I'm not
gonna bail you out with this animal
tries to eat no I'm gonna bring this
home and raise it and then tonked it
every day and you know I'll tell you
what happens is that people get people
get the otic animals as pets and they
think it's cool and then right they'll
angrily a bad idea really bad yeah no I
write your message should be heard do
not get these as pets but my god they're
absolutely they're totally adorable
you